Hey guys,
Good morning.
Hey guys.
We just went for our Visa
interviews for the USA.
Yes we did.
But the main reason we're sending you guys
this video is because we're so busy these
last few weeks with everything that's going on, we
wanted to include you in one of our Bible studies.
A few weeks ago we shared a video of what a
normal day in my life looks like, you know?
Running two YouTube channels
and the whole ministry.
Nikita is in the video as well.
You can watch that video on DLM Men's Lifestyle.
We've got a good DLM meeting
that we're going to share.
Yeah.
But on that video,
I had a Bible study with the team and I didn't
share everything with you and I thought, how about
I invite you guys to join us in that Bible study?
So, here we go!